[Music]
[Music]
congratulations everyone
what an exciting day for all of you it's
really her first day on the job
don't be nervous I won't bite candy
crush can't match him with any yellows
or else we line you up with the yellows
special candies get transported to that
jar the game might think you're a
special candy what if it doesn't
sorry
what if it doesn't think I'm a special
candy oh I'm not too worried about it
we're trying to see if I had somehow
turned into candy weren't you yes I was
and you have not what should I do
what Center an emoji okay be cool
welcome to the secret world inside your
phone we're emojis like me work and live
here each of us does one thing and we
have to nail it every time we are go for
met me what is that
I've got to get this phone fixed this
has never happened before and now alex
has made an appointment to wipe out his
phone I'm not gonna run away from this I
made a mistake but I'm gonna fix it I
think we can make things right we just
have to go to a place where no emoji has
gone before the cloud I know a shortcut
through some apps but no one's ever left
our city and they'll send box after us
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever I've never eaten another piece of
candy again
high five don't do it don't you do it
it's already been in there once need to
get the master password access tonight
this might take a while wait what
access tonight we're gonna have some
dance our way out everybody could dance
see
[Music]